With The Martian out now, let’s take a look
at 15 things you probably didn’t know about
Ridley Scott’s big-screen adaptation of
Andy Weir’s best-selling book.
Director Ridley Scott didn’t want to rely
on visual effects for the sandstorm scene,
and wanted to make it feel real for the actors
and audience, so giant fans were used to fill
the air with dirt and small stones.
Dust got everywhere including inside the air
vents in the actors’ helmets, which made
it tough for them to breathe, so between takes
wardrobe assistants had to help them remove
the helmets.
And the thick dust in the air also meant the
actors could hardly see each other while filming.
Fortunately, the mini-intercom system installed
inside their helmets allowed them to talk
to each other and Scott throughout.
According to Kate Mara, who plays astronaut
Beth Johanssen, the cast used the intercom
to swap jokes and tease each other, which
helped them bond quickly on set.
The sandstorm scene took three days to film
on the Martian exterior set that was built
on one of the biggest soundstages in the world,
Stage 6 at Korda Studios, near Budapest.
As Matt Damon plays astronaut Mark Watney
who gets stranded by himself on Mars, he spent
most of his time filming alone, without the
rest of the cast, for a total of nearly five
weeks.
In fact, his filming schedule only coincided
with Jessica Chastain and the other actors
playing astronauts for three days in mid-December
2014.
And he filmed again with just Chastain for
a couple more days in February 2015.
After plans to film in the Australian Outback
didn’t work out, the filmmakers decided
to shoot many of the Martian sequences on
sets at Korda Studios to give them more control
over the environment.
However, the movie also filmed panoramic views
for 8 days in Jordan’s Wadi Rum desert,
which doubled for Mars.
Other movies that have shot in the same area
include David Lean’s Lawrence of Arabia
and the sci-fi horror The Last Days On Mars.
Back in the studio, a huge green screen, over
300 foot long and 65 foot high, was assembled
so background plates of Wadi Rum could be
added.
And to ensure that shots taken on the stage
matched those from Jordan, the movie’s visual
effects supervisor and cinematographer studied
Wadi Rum’s solar path charts so they knew
the correct lighting direction at all times.
4,000 tons of soil and other materials were
used to create the Martian landscape set.
It took three types of Hungarian soil mixed
together by hand and machine to get the right
colour to match the Wadi Rum desert.
A nursery with artificial lighting and heating
was also built at the studio to grow Watney’s
potatoes, using half-cut spuds, just like
in the movie.
A total of 1,200 potatoes were grown, with
around 8 potatoes per plant.
The Martian’s Rover was modelled on the
Curiosity rover, though the movie’s version
is even bigger.
A team of 22 technicians from the movie crew
and 15 members of the Hungarian Opel Dakar
team constructed two full-scale Rovers for
filming.
But before shooting began in Jordan, the vehicle’s
ability to deal with rough terrain was put
to the test in a Hungarian quarry.
While the solar panels on the vehicle’s
exterior make it look as if it runs on solar
energy, which is part of the story; in reality
it had a 2-litre diesel engine.
The design of the Hermes spacecraft was influenced
by the interlocking modules of the International
Space Station.
The Hermes set was built on several stages
at Korda Studios, and the craft’s bright
white interior is a nod to director Stanley
Kubrick’s classic scif-fi, 2001: A Space
Odyssey.
To make it look like the actors were floating
around in zero gravity, an enormous winch
system was built and suspended above the roofless
set of the Hermes and the actors were harnessed
to wire rigs at the waist, legs and shoulders.
Although the system was mechanised, members
of the stunt team were still needed to pull
harness ropes to make the actors move vertically.
150 metres of truss, 90 metres of track, 70
pulleys, and around 400 metres of rope were
used to build the rig.
To get inspiration for the movie’s spacesuits,
costume designer Janty Yates visited the Johnson
Space Center and the Jet Propulsion Lab, researched
spacesuit designs with the Curator of Space
History at the Smithsonian National Air And
Space Museum, and even saw designs for suits
that are going to be used on missions beyond
2030.
15 suits were made for the film, and the actors
wore them for 10 to 12 hours a day.
The surface suits, which were worn when exploring
Mars, were made of neoprene, which is also
used for wetsuits, and their combined weight
with the helmet was over 30 pounds.
The movie’s Extra-Vehicular Activity suit
or ‘outer space’ suit, which was worn
outside the Hermes spacecraft, is a more streamlined
version of a NASA suit used outside the International
Space Station.
Underneath the suits, there was a system of
cold water tubes to keep the actors cool,
and fans inside their life support backpacks
also channelled air through a hose into their
helmets, which was the same as the cooling
system used in the spacesuits in Interstellar.
If you want to check out some more cool facts
and things you didn’t know about Interstellar,
click right there!
To get inspiration for the movie’s spacesuits,
costume designer Janty Yates visited NASA
facilities, researched spacesuit designs with
the Curator of Space History at the Smithsonian
National Air And Space Museum, and even saw
designs for suits that are going to be used
on missions beyond 2030.
15 suits were made for the film, and the actors
wore them for around 10 hours a day.
The surface suits worn for exploring Mars
in the film are made of neoprene, which is
also used for wetsuits.
The movie’s Extravehicular Activity suit
or ‘outer space’ suit, which was worn
outside the Hermes, is a more streamlined,
less bulky version of the Extravehicular Mobility
Units worn by astronauts on spacewalks at
the International Space Station.
Underneath the suits, there was a system of
cold water tubes to keep the actors cool,
and fans inside their life support backpacks
also channelled air through a hose into their
helmets, which was the same as the cooling
system used in Interstellar’s spacesuits.
If you want to check out some more cool facts
and things you didn’t know about Interstellar,
click right there!
To get good, clear close-ups of the actors’
faces, the helmets made for the movie had
to be bigger than the ones worn by real astronauts.
Also, each helmet’s visor had to be flawless
and ultra-polished to prevent the kind of
glare that makes it very difficult to capture
the faces of real astronauts on camera when
they’re in space.
Again, to keep the actors’ faces visible
while filming, the helmets also had several
lights in them which were operated separately
by a small remote.
The filmmakers worked closely with NASA from
script to shoot.
For example, they were allowed to film rocket
launches at Cape Canaveral, including the
lift-off of the Orion, a spacecraft designed
to eventually enable human exploration of
Mars.
In fact, on board the Orion during its maiden
voyage in December 2014 was the title page
of The Martian script, which included a sketch
of astronaut Mark Watney by director Ridley
Scott!
To prepare for her role as Commander Lewis,
leader of the Mars mission, Jessica Chastain
spent a number of days at NASA’s Jet Propulsion
Laboratory and the Johnson Space Center and
got to go inside a Mars Ascent Vehicle.
Chastain also did background reading on astronauts
including Sally Ride, and spent time with
astronaut and chemist Tracy Caldwell Dyson
who shared her experience of both the technical
and human side of life in space.
On top of that, via a virtual reality headset,
Chastain experienced panoramic images of Mars
taken by the Curiosity rover.
Production designer Arthur Max found much
of his inspiration for the movie’s NASA
sets on a tour of the Johnson Space Center,
led by Dr James Green, who, as well as being
Director of NASA’s Planetary Science Division,
also happens to be a huge fan of Alien!
During the tour, Max spoke with lots of specialists
and took hundreds of photos for reference.
He also inspected the old Apollo mission control
centre and the current Centre, and incorporated
aspects of those into his own vision of NASA’s
next control room in The Martian.
During filming, the monitors in the movie’s
Mission Control Room displayed a mixture of
graphics, high-res satellite imagery and video
footage from NASA.
Ridley Scott preferred this to using green
screen and adding the images in post-production
as it allowed him to use the images on the
screens as light sources and it gave the actors
something real to react to.
By the way, director Colin Trevorrow did something
similar in Jurassic World.
And if you’d like to find out more things
you didn’t know about that movie, click
right there.
Filming in Budapest also took place at The
Whale, a cultural and commercial centre located
along the Danube River.
The state-of-the-art building was used for
scenes set in the offices of NASA director
Teddy Sanders and media relations director
Annie Montrose, played by Jeff Daniels and
Kristen Wiig, and it was also used for scenes
involving conference rooms, a break room and
coffee shop, and a main entrance.
To make the maximum use of the building’s
open spaces, fake concrete walls were placed
on wheels and used to quickly create and then
change the layout of offices, as needed for
filming.
Kate Mara was already such a huge fan of Ridley
Scott before she was even cast in The Martian
that she had named one of her dogs Lucius,
after the Emperor’s nephew in the Oscar-winning
historical drama, Gladiator.
Now, let me know in the comments below, what
are your favourite sci-fi movies?
And what other movies would you like me to
cover in my Things You Didn’t Know videos?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know, as well as
movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!